Works of art can be perplexing, and sometimes,
they can knock you dead.
Netflix's Velvet Buzzsaw takes that idea and
runs with it, giving life to pieces of art
that might take your breath away permanently.
If you're having trouble figuring out what
the film is trying to say, worry no more as
we break down the bloody end of Velvet Buzzsaw.
Don't be fooled by the glossy sheen.
Despite a high art atmosphere, a generous
budget, and a cast stacked with A-listers,
at its heart, Velvet Buzzsaw is as trashy
a horror movie as any installment of Friday
the 13th.
But as far as plot goes, the movie can more
accurately be described as an art world version
of Final Destination.
Instead of the victims being generally unsympathetic,
cookie-cutter teens, they're uniquely loathsome,
insufferably pretentious grown adults.
You're flat-out not supposed to like them,
which makes it all the more exciting when
the time comes to sit back and watch them
suffer.
Much like Final Destination, this is essentially
a slasher movie with a metaphysical villain.
In the Final Destination series, the enemy
is Death itself.
In Velvet Buzzsaw, things are a little bit
more complicated.
Here, the killer is the vengeful spirit of
a deceased artist, persisting from beyond
the grave to lethally punish those who would
seek to profit off of his and others' art.
If it sounds a little silly, that's because
it's supposed to be.
Velvet Buzzsaw is not a particularly scary
movie.
As far as genre goes, it's best to describe
it as a horror-comedy, with the emphasis on
comedy.
But it's not a very funny movie either, as
far as knee-slapping jokes are concerned.
Above all else, the movie is a satire about
bad people.
Its humor comes from the absurdity of the
characters and their ridiculous world, which
they all take quite seriously.
Think about the characters' names, which take
pretentiousness to the point of parody.
There's Morf Vandewalt, Rhodora Haze, Jon
Dondon, and of course, the vengeful artist
Vetril Dease.
All of these people are insufferable at best
and evil at worst, generally only caring about
themselves.
With characters like this, the movie's world
is already a total horror show, making the
killings extra cathartic.
A key to understanding the movie is realizing
that it's not really trying to frighten you.
When these characters get what's coming to
them, you're supposed to be amused.
Some of the first lines of dialogue in Velvet
Buzzsaw come from a mechanized artwork called
Hoboman, a mixed-media piece on display at
Art Basel.
Jake Gyllenhaal's critic character, Morf,
has arrived to size up the piece, as well
as whatever else catches his eye at the show.
“Have you ever felt invisible?”
The question appears to be commenting on homeless
people, but it also applies to Velvet Buzzsaw's
conception of the artist, as well as the bitter
grudge that drives the movie's story along.
For a movie about the art world, very few
artists actually appear — most of the characters
are at these shows to buy, sell, hype up,
or reject art.
The artists themselves are spoken of like
brand names, with their work being praised
for its popularity and monetary value above
all else.
They're not treated like people who put their
hearts and souls into their creations — especially
the artist at the center of the plot.
Morf determines the value of art by filtering
it all through his own perspective.
What he doesn't like, doesn't sell.
He may not be a gallery owner or an outright
sellout like Rhodora, but he's still a gatekeeper,
and a crucial part of the art world ecosystem.
When Morf walks into the Art Basel show at
the start of the movie, he passes by a sign
that reads "There's no confusion in my house"
a statement that reflects his status as a
critic.
Confusion only exists in Morf's personal life.
When he's at work, he speaks with exacting
certainty.
Morf is there to pass judgment.
In his world, it's up to him to determine
what qualifies as quality art.
He dismisses the hit of the show, Hoboman,
as a derivative work that doesn't impress
him.
His assessment effectively cancels out all
the other praise, leading the piece to languish
in storage after his bad review snuffs out
all interest in it.
"Your review of Hoboman killed the sale.
Instead of being seen, it's gathering dust
at a storage facility."
"I am not your mouthpiece."
Morf's critiques have direct consequences,
with some bad reviews apparently being so
distressing that they basically threaten artists'
lives.
In one instance, Morf is told about an artist
who tailspins into self-destruction after
being emotionally devastated by one of his
brutal reviews.
"Ricky got drunk and crashed his car last
night.
He’s in a coma.”
“I heard he was crushed."
“By the car?"
"Your review."
In the world of Velvet Buzzsaw, Morf's critiques
are presented as a kind of violence, justifying
his own eventual death at the hands of the
living Hoboman.
Velvet Buzzsaw positions itself as a critique
of the commercialization of art, with the
vengeful spirit of Vetril Dease serving as
the message's main vessel.
But it's important to remember that Dease
himself was not a particularly good person.
As Morf and the other characters eventually
discover, Dease was very violent, and emotionally
disturbed.
Death didn't turn him into a killer spirit
it really just let his dark soul loose on
the world.
Despite all of this, it seems that everything
would have been fine if Josephina had just
followed Dease's wishes, and allowed his work
to be destroyed.
Usually, blaming the victim is a nasty thing.
In the context of Velvet Buzzsaw, in which
the victims are pretty much always operating
out of their own self-interest, it feels pretty
justified.
The killer is a bad person, sure — but there
are no innocent victims in this movie.
As haunting as Dease's paintings appear, it's
not necessarily his artwork that's carrying
a curse.
Sure, his actual blood may be all mixed up
with the paint he used, but that's more a
signpost for the movie's themes than a key
to its twisted magic.
The actual function of Dease's "curse" is
to weaponize all art, not just his own paintings.
This is why Hoboman comes to life to attack
Morf, why Sphere is able to cut Gretchen's
arm off in the movie's best kill, and why
Josephina gets consumed by a roomful of living
paint.
The movie doesn't explain its rules very well,
but the unifying thread of all the deaths
is that they're committed by works of art,
against people who see art as little more
than something to be bought and sold.
With these characters being so steeped in
the art world, they're always vulnerable.
They don't appreciate the power that surrounds
them, and end up paying for their ignorance
with their lives.
After a few kills have been tallied up, this
message becomes really, really obvious.
But the killings aren’t as simple as “’selling
art’ equals ‘you die.’”
They’re more of an indictment of people’s
whole philosophies.
The plunder of Dease's paintings results in
multiple deaths; Bryson, the gallery installer
who steals some of the artwork; Jon, the gallery
owner, whose body Coco finds; Gretchen, whose
body Coco finds; Josephina, whose greedy desire
to raise her status as an exhibitor led her
to steal Dease's art in the first place; and
Morf, the destructive critic, whose body Coco
also finds.
Poor Coco.
“AAAH!
F--- me!”
Morf spends most of the movie getting increasingly
suspicious about the many deaths happening
around him, but the only character to figure
out what's going on is Rhodora.
After Bryson, Jon, Gretchen, Josephina, and
Morf all die, Rhodora accepts that the insane
scenario of "Dease bringing art to life to
kill people" probably has some merit to it.
Sensing that she's probably next on the chopping
block, Rhodora hires a team of movers to strip
her home of all artwork — every image, every
drawing, every postcard, counting up to 47
pieces in total.
Satisfied that the job is done, she starts
to rest more easily — until she feels a
little tickle on the back of her neck.
The "Velvet Buzzsaw" tattoo — a band logo
from Rhodora's days as a punk musician — is
one piece of art she couldn't get rid of,
leaving her helpless as it grinds to life
to kill her dead.
At the beginning of the movie, Rhodora's old
band is implied by the artist Damrish to have
started from a sincere place before losing
the plot, presumably becoming more of a brand
name and a way of making money than a purely
artistic outlet.
Basically, she's a sellout, and she knows
it.
"The early stuff was great, then it became
what, like self-parody?"
Damrish, being only six months removed from
a life of poverty, is still in tune with his
creative roots, and acutely sensitive to the
idea of selling out — a path Rhodora committed
to long ago for the sake of getting rich.
It's a decision that ultimately dooms her,
guiding her directly, over the years, to a
most unexpected death.
There's a moment at the beginning of Velvet
Buzzsaw in which John Malkovich's character,
an artist named Piers, expresses a desire
to get away from the tiresome circus of art
as business, and return to something pure.
When we meet him at Art Basel, he's successful,
sober, and creatively unsatisfied.
He seems to be unhappy, and his state of mind
is a key thing to keep in mind as you unpack
the movie's themes.
"I am fighting to get back to creation, to
revelation, the billion years of energy sparking
through our brain."
As the movie eventually concludes, this path
is a righteous one.
Writer-director Dan Gilroy talked about the
themes Velvet Buzzsaw explores in an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter, saying,
"I was very interested in the idea of the
relationship between art and commerce in today's
world.
It's a very uneasy relationship.
[…] That's not to say that commercial success
diminishes a work, but it doesn't define it,
either.
I wanted to get at the idea that art is more
than a commodity."
Ultimately, the movie is about elevating the
pure act of creation over crass commercialization.
That's why the man on the street at the movie's
end — a real hoboman — isn't in any danger
from selling the Dease art he finds following
Rhodora's death.
Sold for cheap on the street, the art is judged
on pure aesthetics, not by perceived value.
Dease wanted his work destroyed, but at the
end of the movie, it's out in the world anonymously,
which also seems to be an acceptable fate.
His body of work is no longer a eight-figure
batch of commodities, but once again pieces
of art for art's sake.
Velvet Buzzsaw expresses its themes not just
through the people it kills, but also by the
people it doesn't.
Poor Coco, who stumbles across so many of
the movie's dead bodies, never gets a higher-level
job that she so covets.
Because of the distance she maintains from
the art industry's rotten moral core, she
survives Dease's wrath.
Damrish, haunted by gazing into a Dease painting
and feeling as though it's watching him, just
gets up and leaves the movie at one point,
sensing the danger and running for his life.
As for Piers, he goes hermit and starts drinking
again, surviving out of his desire to get
away from the alienating commercial side of
the art business.
It's an amusing message for the movie to commit
to, but it really does go there — going
back to being a drunk restores Piers' creativity,
and basically saves his life.
"I think sober hasn't been good for him."
"Well this was done fifteen years ago - Piers
was in the full bloom of alcoholism here."
"Exactly."
In letting these three characters survive,
the movie is saying that they're all on the
correct paths.
In the final shot of the movie, beneath the
credits, Piers walks on a beach, scratching
shapes in the sand with a stick.
In close-up, it seems as though there could
be some bigger message in what he's doing.
But as the camera pans back, it becomes clear
that there is no deeper meaning to his drawings.
He's creating just for fun.
His colleagues made art into something to
consume, and so got consumed by it.
Piers goes back to basics, seeking that primal
creative energy.
He ends the movie looking drunk and joyful
with his life intact, performing for no one
in particular, drawing aimless circles on
the beach.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.